[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
wednesday july 6th i'm julie chang for
the wall street journal filling in for
zoe thomas
european lawmakers voted to approve two
new pieces of digital legislation on
tuesday the laws would address
anti-competitive behavior by tech
companies and harmful or illegal online
content
taken together the new rules are the
most far-reaching efforts by western
countries to rein in big tech in at
least a generation but they're also
likely to lead to clashes between
regulators and tech companies over how
they should be applied
here to tell us more is wsj tech
reporter sam schechner who's been
covering the story for us hi sam thanks
for coming on the show always a pleasure
so sam can you start us off by telling
us more about the two new laws passed in
the eu what exactly do they entail
well these are laws that the eu proposed
just over
a year and a half ago it's remarkably
quick for any kind of legislation
especially in the eu
and they're aimed at addressing what
policymakers here say
are
you know abuses by dominant companies on
one hand and also a failure by companies
in the social media space and e-commerce
space they purport to deal with harmful
content which are two of the big kind of
pressure points around tech companies
globally so the first one is called the
digital markets act that's the digital
competition law and it has all kinds of
very specific
obligations
that it puts on very large companies
defined by their market cap and their
number of business users and consumer
users and the basic idea is that over
many years there have been a bunch of
antitrust cases that the eu has tried to
bring against some of these companies
and some of them have been successful
some of them haven't some of them are
still in court
in this case they want to just kind of
make the remedies that you might win
after a protracted anti-trust battle
they want to make them preemptive
requirements for any large company so
things like
hey you can't if you're a large platform
make your goods and services more
visible on your platform than those of
competitors which recapitulates a case
that the eu brought against google and
its shopping service which is still in
court
there's also obligations around for
instance allowing other app stores onto
your devices which is something that the
eu is interested in pushing on apple for
instance so that's the digital markets
act the digital services act imposes
a kind of sliding scale of requirements
on social media companies leading up to
the very largest companies have a whole
bunch of auditing requirements and
personnel requirements and they
basically have to be able to show that
they're doing everything they can to
deal with potentially harmful content
that they have robust systems in place
that they have appeals mechanisms if
content is taken down but maybe it
shouldn't have been
and
you know it's going to force companies
to have large teams of content
moderators and
independent appeals processes that
satisfy the law or under both of these
laws if they don't comply the companies
could face potentially massive fines in
the billions or tens of billions of
dollars
and you've been talking to the big
players that would be affected by these
rules as well as some of the smaller
companies how have they been responding
well you know i think a lot of the
companies are taking a somewhat cautious
outlook on this at least publicly they
don't want to
you know poke a regulator who's suddenly
going to have massive power over them so
in general the comments are we're
looking at it we're going to comply of
course
you know when you get into the details
some of them express publicly and and
especially privately concern about how
some of these rules will be applied and
how workable they'll really be in
reality and you know apple is
particularly concerned about the
requirement that it allow other app
stores onto its devices saying that that
could be a security issue and you have
you know also some smaller social media
companies that still would be covered by
the digital services act saying at least
privately that the law is too onerous
and that only the biggest companies
really could afford to do all of the the
things that are asked all of what they
would call box checking exercises that
are asked in the dsa and that in a way
it would help them at the expense of
smaller companies so you know there's
going to be a lot of griping and
potentially some you know court appeals
into the future so the european
parliament voted to approve the two laws
now what does this mean going forward
what's next
well the laws were effectively agreed a
couple months ago this is sort of the
biggest high profile hurdle to kind of
rubber stamping that agreement next the
member states have to approve the laws
in you know sort of the european
equivalent of what would be the us
senate and once they've both signed off
then it becomes law it gets published
and you know the european equivalent of
the federal register and then in each of
the laws there's different periods
before certain provisions become
effective but within the you know next
year or so
many of these provisions will apply and
so what we have is companies already
before the ink is even printed much less
dried working on
compliance they have teams figuring out
what might work and they're sending
suggestions already for how they think
you know some of their services should
or shouldn't apply under different
provisions so those negotiations or
suggestions are are already underway and
you know we're going to enter into a
really furious period of of trying to
figure out how these rules will apply to
big tech companies and i think everyone
around the world is going to be watching
how this plays out whether it turns into
a
road map or a cautionary tale is
something that we'll be looking at
closely
alright that was our reporter sam
schuchner sam thank you so much for
being here
it's great to speak with you thanks for
having me
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com and if you
like our show please rate and review it
you can do that wherever you get your
podcasts i'm julie chang for the wall
street journal thanks for listening
[Music]
you